[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Ross Tucker joins us now
hi Ross what did you think of the Aaron
Rodgers video there
I thought it was hilarious I thought it
was amazing I did not realize that it
was Nicholas Cage for Con Air until they
showed that they did the comparison I
just thought he came in trying to look
awesome and looked like a dude I didn't
know he was trying to imitate Nicholas
Cage from Conair
uh I don't know I don't know if anybody
has talked to him about it like did he
actually do this on purpose because uh
if he didn't that's amazing but if he
did that's amazing as well
well the thing that's so interesting to
me about it remember last year Dan his
whole look the whole training camp and
the first part of the season was designs
that he could look like John Wick at a
Halloween party yes I mean Aaron is
really into this look more power to him
I don't know how you can be that
concerned with your appearance and
looking like a Halloween party or your
arrival at training camp and still
breathe a two-time MVP but I guess it's
working for him I guess he's got that
perfect balance in life Ross Tucker CBS
Westwood one color analyst host of the
Ross Tucker football podcast and uh also
covers the Philadelphia Eagles check
them out on social media at Ross Tucker
NFL where do you want to start where do
you what what topic is uh front and
center for you I think probably based on
my social media when I've seen probably
the Kyler Murray contract clause which I
heard you guys talk about a lot
yesterday and one thing I haven't heard
a lot of people talk a lot about how
about how about your boy Dan Bill
Belichick heard you talking with Peter
about him the other day having a overall
one minute
unbelievable Mac Jones Soliloquy the
likes of which we've never heard before
but I wonder if I combined everything
that he said about Brady in his entire
career in New England was it longer than
the one minute Soliloquy that he paid
tribute to Mac Jones with yesterday no
it wasn't and that's why I said on
Twitter at Ross Tucker NFL Patriots fans
are so mad at me they're like you're a
liar he said there's no quarterback he'd
rather have watched the video when they
did the top 100 players all I'm saying
is any Patriots fans out there seating
included okay if you can find a clip
of Bill Belichick at a press conference
being asked a question about Tom Brady
and gushing about him for over a minute
straight on just a generic question I
would love to see it I will admit I was
wrong but Dan I never heard him like
that now I don't know if he's just being
honest I don't know if he feels like Mac
Jones needs that yeah maybe he feels
like the rest of the team needs to hear
Bill say that about Mac Jones maybe he's
just getting softer in his old age you
know you hear some of the things he says
now and does he definitely I don't know
if he's got grandkids now or what but
he's definitely softened up a little bit
maybe he didn't think Brady uh ever
needed that but all I ever heard him say
about Brady is
you know uh I've said it I've said it a
million times there's no quarterback I'd
rather have that's all he would ever say
well there's no quarterback he went all
I mean he was like oh Mac Jones he's
better at this and he's this and he got
better it was very very interesting to
me as a guy that's been around him and
been watching him for you know last 20
plus years but when you were around
Belichick when you played in New England
and Grant it was limited time but how
forthcoming is he in saying something
nice
you know outside of a press conference
just within the team
very rarely
very rarely in fact I don't know if we
ever talked about this before you know I
do a lot of speaking engagements Dan and
and the The Business Leaders you know
they do a q a and they're always like
what kind of leader was Belichick what
makes him so special and I'm always like
well I don't know the start of every day
you watch the five worst plays from
practice the day before it's almost a
hundred percent negative reinforcement
like I don't know what to tell you guys
I don't recommend this for your entire
business necessarily I don't want you to
come in and tell Phil he did a terrible
job on the radial tires but that's the
way Belichick is I mean people want to
hear the secret sauce 8 A.M meeting it's
the five worst plays from the day before
and your goal is to not be a part of
that and he will rip anybody he busts
your chops he makes fun of you your
primary motivation at least when I was
there Dan oh 506 but I've heard it was
still like that fairly recently you
don't want to be on that low light video
at the start of the start of the meeting
8 am every day
I know you mentioned uh us talking about
what's going on with Kyler Murray I'm
just trying to figure out who does this
benefit by being leaked to the media
unless it's another agent who would have
leaked this to Ian Rappaport I can't
imagine Kyler Murray's agent is going to
go hey got this for you can you give me
a positive spin on this uh it feels like
maybe somebody is saying can you believe
that he signed this contract or his
agent agreed to this contract
I don't think it's a leak I think there
are people especially with a contract
that this big that read all of the terms
if anyone specifically put it out there
I would think it's the Cardinals because
they would know that eventually someone
people are going to read these contracts
right because they need to know it's the
second biggest contract on an average
per year basis maybe the Cardinals put
it out there because the more I think
about it then
they're not dumb people they knew this
would get out either soon or eventually
and they did it anyway you know they
they wanted this clause in anyway so it
seems like on some level I don't know if
they're trying to embarrass him then or
uh put a chip on his shoulder but they
knew this would get out it's a terrible
look for Kyler I mean it's embarrassing
I'm embarrassed a little bit for him
that this comes out like this I think
the Cardinals are hoping this is the
kick in the rear that he needs to be a
more engaged player off the field
because I've heard stuff I'm sure you
have as well you know I I have heard he
is an all-timer when it comes to video
games and these guys you know they're
all all in their early mid-20s a lot of
the guys like video games but Kyler
Murray takes it to another level from
what people have told me and I think
it's a concern I think it's it's
obviously a concern otherwise they
wouldn't have put this in his contract
but then to me it wouldn't have been
independent study it would be like study
with one of our people with one of our
coaches or what why independent I mean
independent study how do you know he's
actually doing it I would have had joint
study it would be mandated joint study
with the quarterback coach you know
after hours or whatever it is yeah I
would have a tutor there without calling
it a tutor but I would just say you know
the quarterback's coach is going to
visit you one hour after practice and
then you know that way at least you know
that you're getting an hour with the
coach that and and I keep saying what is
what is Cliff Kingsbury's role
because he kind of shook this off like
hey it's no big deal you know he said
well he could only stay mad at somebody
so long he's making a quarter of a
billion dollars you still didn't answer
the question how did this get to
management that he wasn't studying
enough for you so there there's more
here it's just people are trying to put
their head in the sand like no there's
nothing to see here no big deal it's not
a secret that the Cardinals would like
more from him from a leadership and
preparation standpoint yeah you know but
this day and this is the way it is man I
mean Kyler knows that there's 10 teams
out there he's a top 15 quarterback in
the NFL all day there's 10 teams out
there at least five that would give him
the exact same contract Tyler knows it
he wanted his money now I don't blame
him the Cardinals looked around and said
we don't really want to give him this
money now we don't really want to commit
to him we want to see more but what what
are our other options you know go go
back to the draft they don't really have
any better options so this is sort of
how they decided to uh split the baby so
to speak we'll give them 100 million
dollars we'll have them under contract
for seven years but we need to have some
something in writing that he's actually
going to take the next step as a leader
he's Ross Tucker he works for CBS
Westwood one is a color analyst the
situation with the Niners feels tricky
because you can't wait to get Jimmy
Garoppolo out the door and you got Trey
Lance there who it's now his job he's
young he's inexperienced and this is a
Super Bowl well I'll say a playoff
roster that he inherits here you got
Kyle Shanahan who normally you're in
good hands if Kyle is your head coach or
offensive coordinator
so what can go wrong in San Francisco in
this situation
well Jimmy's not going to be on the week
one roster in San Francisco because then
his 24 million dollars would be fully
guaranteed for the year and the Niners
aren't going to do that and that's
probably the biggest impediment along
with his shoulder to him getting traded
is people don't want to pay Jimmy
Garoppolo 24 million dollars this year
most people don't have 24 million
dollars in space right now so they need
to kind of work that out like Baker
Mayfield did with the Carolina Panthers
to make his contract a little bit more
palatable Plus in Jimmy's case the
physical is going to be really important
the Niners they're not even going to
have them practice stand they're putting
him on Ice that the last thing they can
have happen is he gets hurt somehow and
they're on the hook for 24 million
dollars Kyle Shannon says they're not
even going to practice I mean he's just
gonna stand there and watch practice and
wait until he gets traded the part of it
I think is really interesting
is the teams that aren't interested in
him right what are you saying if you're
the Atlanta Falcons or the Seattle
Seahawks or any of these teams Dan where
Jimmy would clearly be much better you
you are telling your fans we are not
trying to win games this year because
they could get Jimmy they could get him
so the next question after that is how
do the fans feel about it the fans of
these teams in Atlanta and Seattle how
do you feel that your organization is
telling you hey like we're not really
trying to win this year you know we'll
see what happens but we want to get a
high pick next year or maybe we'll
during the year play a young kid and see
what happens but if some of these teams
whose quarterback situations are
horrible don't try to trade for Jimmy
they're sending a very loud and clear
message to their fans
Tom Brady picks up Julio Jones they just
made it official that they signed him to
a one-year deal what do you think of the
move
no downside I've seen nothing in terms
of the financials which means
he probably went there for peanuts
relatively speaking and this is part of
the value of having Tom Brady I'm not
saying the Bucks are going to win the
Super Bowl because Julio Jones is there
all I'm saying is Julio Jones is there
because he thinks it's his best chance
to win a Super Bowl you know Julio's
made a ton of money his stats are crazy
I think he feels like that's the only
thing missing and that this is his best
chance to get it they've signed other
guys the last three years for the exact
same reasoning exact same logic it's
part of the added value that having
Brady as your quarterback brings Before
I Let You Go next hour we're going to be
picking which playoff team will not be a
playoff team this year let me start in
the AFC if I said you had to pick
Raiders Bengals Titans Patriots bills
Steelers Chiefs doesn't make the
playoffs
Raiders and Titans are the two that jump
out to me and over the Steelers to a
lesser extent oh oh I'm sorry yeah no
Steelers are not making it okay all
right all right if I had that's a good
you know
you know it's yours though they never
talking about Seattle and Atlanta where
they're not really trying to win this
year they're kind of in a rebuilding
year yeah I don't ever remember that the
Steelers refuse to do that like the
Steelers they will not quit on any
season they will not give up I wouldn't
be surprised this dealer somehow with
trubisky or Pickett win nine games 20
years since they had a losing record
it's crazy they it's one things I
respect
because everybody always says uh the
worst place you want to be is mediocre
you either need to be really good or
really bad the Steelers refuse to relent
they would never do that to their fan
base and I respect the heck out of them
for it all right NFC Cardinals Rams
Niners Packers Cowboys Eagles Buccaneers
most likely to miss the playoffs
um
I'll go Arizona Cardinals yeah yeah I
think I think they're in a bad spot plus
their offensive line I mean then the
left guard thought he was retired and
lost weight they had to convince him to
come out of retirement I don't remember
I don't know if the center wanted to
retire wanted more money but he didn't
go to mini camp and they got The Right
Guard couldn't start for the Giants I
mean when when you when you watch a
Super Bowl highlight video right on NFL
films that's not the start of the video
the start of the video is not the one
guy I thought he was retired the other
guy wanted to and the other guy can't
start for the Giants and you don't have
the video don't have DeAndre Hopkins
either for uh the first half of the
season it's not good and this I mean
you've interviewed him you know your
interview with him when he's coming out
for the draft got a lot of attention
this thing with Kyler Dan
it's only going to go one of two ways
you know this clause and this contract
he's either gonna step up his game or
get to the next level or the heat is
going to be such I mean What's it gonna
be like when he goes into these stadiums
I mean fans are going to be razzing him
about this they're going to have like
books and and and talk about study hall
this is it has a chance to be ugly in
Arizona they obviously are taking a big
risk here and a big chance that they
think it will go the other way well
you're gonna have you know video
controllers that people are going to
bring in yeah well and yeah and not only
Dan does he have to do four hours of
independent study if he doesn't do six
hours he's not allowed to go to the
dance Friday night or the prom
foreign
thank you Ross see you then that's Ross
Tucker CBS Westwood one color analyst
former uh offensive lineman
nailed that joke yeah Patrick lugged me